maintenant
voici
il est ici il est ici
mère père est ici le roi ma dame
le roi
ton destin est fixé et tu ne peux pas y échapper
maintenant tu m'as manqué mon fils
un jour ce royaume sera à
toi merci père
mon roi
[Musique]
père
souviens-toi
étrangère
[Musique
] ta mère je tuerai ton combustible
pourquoi se serait-il caché dans un
endroit aussi infernal
pour trouver ce qui m'a été volé
et quel est
ce royaume
tu dois choisir entre la gentillesse pour
tes proches
ou la haine pour tes ennemis
ta force se brise  les os de l'homme
j'ai la ruse de leur briser l'esprit
et nuit après nuit nous exécuterons mon
serment de vengeance
je te vengerai père
je ne te tuerai pas